welcome to the week ahead from the
spectator we've got 10 days left to save
the Union the opinion polls look like
Britain might snap in two
it's difficult to think about many other
topics the newspapers all seem trivial
by comparison to the fact that the
country is just a few days away from
dissolution or could be I'm joined by
James Forsythe Elizabeth Hardman to
discuss the incredible situation we find
herself in and what if anything can be
done to reverse it James David Cameron
he is not the most popular man in
Scotland yeah he is the prime minister
of a country which looks as if in my
break apart what can you do well I think
once he is a declaration in on problem
Wednesday from the free party leaders
down here cameraman of Alan Clegg about
a timetable for devolve amor pass to
Scotland and whether they think it
baffles me you know as a Scot as to why
they think this is going to work and
because this is I mean if people want
more power to the Scottish Parliament
they'll vote for independence and yet
they seem to be thinking this war I've
seen no evidence this will have any
traction on well I think the D by Max is
that is the most popular option in
Scotland so I think now how many more
the pull shoot independent the first
time having it fought so hard to keep
that question off the ballot paper the
unionist policies are now basically
saying I vote for no is a vote for debo
max I was having sums up the entire
muddled way but this campaign has been
run Cameron's gonna stay out of Scotland
this week I think that the belief is
that the field needs to be left clear
for labour to make that kind of
left-wing case for the Union so if you
go ahead and brown and Ed Miliband today
you'll go on there a week today and then
he will make it and I hope you will make
a really passionate cases even I mean I
think this is the point which is you
know I'm not a Scott except in the
vaguest ancestral sense but we would be
as a country we would be so much worse
off without each other and I mean this
is there is a complete lack of poetry to
eat to the Union s campaign you know
this country
no coincidence that the greatest 300
years in the history of both England and
Scotland have been the three hundred
years since 1707 since the Act of Union
we've done great things together there's
many many more things to do and we need
to get that across that sense but the
rest of the country desperately wants
Scotland to say all the polls show that
and also that you know look maybe we are
gonna have to have a new constitutional
model for the UK maybe we all have to
become a much more federal state but
let's actually keep the country together
and then we can debate all that Isabel
so I mean the Tory trips in Scotland are
it was it mildly not the strongest force
in politics is this now Labour's
election to winner Toulouse yes it is
partly because the the wavering voters
who will decide the result are labour
voters so that's why you don't really
want Tories going up there and even out
of the summer conservative MPs he went
up to campaign and Scotland were told
that sort of tone down the taurine
astone open a door and say hello I'm
with Tory MP because that's not really
going to win any votes but I think the
problem is is that Alistair Darling
doesn't really do campaigning in poetry
he does it all in prose and when he
tries to show emotion he just looks like
he's had too much coffee so this is one
of the problems it is if he does try to
sort of change gears over the next few
days
he'll just took a little bit agitated
rather than as though he's actually been
emotional I think the other problem for
labour is that darling has obviously
been working very hard on this Miliband
has made his intervention some of which
have been slightly alarming over the
weekend about putting guards on the
border but some of their colleagues have
been very unhelpful so as James wrote on
coffeehouse over the weekend
Andy Burnham has been striding around
Trafalgar Square talking about the
threat to the NHS of Greater
privatisation in England and he's tried
to caveat this by saying what you know
it doesn't apply to Scotland but
Alexander is saying what he does in
quoting over and over again this morning
i was listening to Angus McNeal on the
radio saying Labour's shadow Health
Minister has been talking about the
threat of privatization they're
absolutely thrilled that everything Andy
Byrnes do he could have waited until
after the 18th to do his NHS thing and
then all's fair in love and politics but
actually this is too serious for that
she was banished together is politicians
and business figures it is the
establishment personified and what
you've got going on is the SNP say
if you don't if there's anything you
don't like about the current situation
vote for independence it might be
different what we're going to need is
people to fill this gap we're going to
need the rest of UK
we're gonna need fingers from outside
politics and business to come forward
and make the case for the Union make the
case that yeah this is a great country
and we can make it an even better
country I think one of the other things
they need to counter is this pernicious
myth that somehow Scotland will be a
more equal and fair country lots of
unicorns and rainbows in it and they
voted to become independent actually if
you look at some of the outcomes under
SNP land policies that they're not any
better and there's no evidence that that
a SNP ruled Scotland who would be fairer
and more evil but it seems to be driving
those labor voters towards the yes base
this is what I find the most baffling
aspect of the debate that we had 15
years of devolution with the SNP and the
Scottish Parliament have been in charge
of education in charge of health so if
home rule was this great golden bullet
then the NHS surely in Scotland should
be a lot better than it is so the school
should be shame newman's with the
progress that hasn't happened but these
are some of the massive problems over
the evolution settlement is it is it's
always perfectly designed for the
Nationalists because but they have
enough power to gain credit for the good
things but Westminster still has an
awful thority for them to blame
Westminster for the bad things they even
blame them for health education
dissolving using labor on Wales which is
normally used to shame labour in England
as an example of how Westminster is
ruining health systems when he was
campaigning in the second debate which I
thought was audacious yeah so what you
what is quite clear is that devolution
has caused massive problems and we that
is the the status rewarded what what is
clear is that the status quo is
unsustainable because this is the
perfect breeding conditions for
nationalism we need it we know a new
system a much more federal system so
that you can say so the contagion of
Scots look with the exception of the
following areas about defense foreign
policy interest rates you know your
government is in charge but the thing is
James that these points for every reason
are not getting through and and anybody
who followed the 95 Kubik a referendum
as I did oddly will get a complete sense
of deja vu
the Federalists complained that no logic
no argument could puncture the
nationalists rhetoric because they were
talking but conjured the dream of a new
tomorrow offer we're going to start all
over again so let's create a sort of
pacifist utopia
so as Alex Massey wrote in a very good
blog forum coffeehouse this weekend it's
difficult to dismantle an idea but you
can combat it with another idea you can
combat
salmon's talk of a New Scotland in many
ways laudable with talk of Britain and
what Britain has been there when Britain
can become but I put it to you that
these arguments are not being made
because they're not felt I think it's
also because we've got this cultural
cringe when I look at you I don't see a
foreign art I think when you look at me
you don't see a foreigner this is this
is why this is softer now we need to get
the audience or two weeks rooms and no
no but we need to get the argument down
to this level because somehow what has
happened is salmon has managed to make
what he's doing um sound far more
reasonable than it is Alex Salmond is
trying to divide families he's trying to
say to people your relatives are
foreigners he is trying to say that we
shouldn't that we shouldn't have the
same care and concern the people on one
side or the other of the old Hadrian's
Wall but we need to reject that we need
to talk about the fact that when um when
Britons do travel around the world we
don't look to see whether they're Scots
Welsh or Northern Irish before we decide
what we're concerned we feel for them as
fellow countrymen and fellow country
women they're our fellow citizens we
need to make the argument that we are
Britons together and that salmon is
trying to divide us he's trying to split
people up he's trying to force people in
Scotland to choose where Scott social
British and we need to reject that false
choice but we also need to make clear
what Salmond is trying to do Sam is
trying to make independence sound very
much like Devo max now he claims that
the Scots in English will still have a
social Union no he won't
you need to make the case that he is
splitting up this country so Isabel with
only 10 days to go what can be done I
mean ed Miliband is as unpopular in
Scotland as David Cameron which is
saying something I can't think of a last
Labour leader to be no more popular than
the tortilla leader in Scotland so if Ed
Miliband
can get through a David Cameron can get
through I mean James says we need
to do things who is the we I think we
need those high-level cultural
interventions that talk about that the
union in a positive way rather than Ana
if you leave this bad thing will happen
rather than actually talking about you
know if you if you leave you'll lose all
these wonderful things and these are the
wonderful things that hold us together
and I think you can't have that from a
politician partly because people just
switch off when they see politicians I
don't know you might maybe hope to see
someone really high-profile intervening
possibly even something from the Queen
he's appeared on quite a few front pages
in the past few days but but there is a
question of who can politicians actually
give up to and say well she we're not
good enough I mean Jeff the Queen did
consider intervening in Canada we know
this because she was hoaxed called by a
Canadian radio station who said to her
we make a televised intervention and she
agreed do you think that would help now
I think there is a danger of an intern
leaving a solving the question
politicizing the monarch I mean there's
a danger this isn't this isn't political
about this is my country
but there's there is a there is a there
is a supplementary danger I would say
that the Queen is obviously this is a
personís to gather is the establishment
the cui is definitely the establishment
it's got a higher approval rating with
any politicians yeah and there are some
people who think that the SNP abandoning
republicanism has led to a tempering of
the Royal Family's pro-union sentiments
in this whole business um I personally
would warm up what I would love to see
is is people getting on buses and trains
from all across the UK and heading up to
Edinburgh to Glasgow to make the case I
mean I'm just seek to see people to see
that when they see these people marching
through the streets do they look at them
and do they say oh that's a bunch of
foreigners or do they say no but these
are our friends and our family so we at
the spectator or what we've invited
people to write in am a right letter to
me editor at spectator Jose Coto at UK
and saying discuss why they should vote
to stay in we got in this morning to
work and found a huge number of
responses which is birds well for this
week's issue
but what else if somebody's watching
this somebody and Cornwall and Liverpool
and Newcastle they want to think we do
want to think of the country to break up
without their having done something no
matter how small something well it's
what is known as hands across the Union
getting people all the way along the
border to link up and send the message
and score something that's I think
that's a good idea but I mean I think
there needs to be something organized
something clear that enables people to
have per se and I really do think though
that just but just if it is just this if
it is just saying well I've got a cousin
who lives in our brief so I'll call them
up and say something look I really hope
you don't leave I mean that could make a
real difference and we might not have a
boat but we care deeply about the result
and we we passionately believe that this
country is better and greater for the
fact that Scotland is part of it isn't
the second extender everyone is as
passionate as chains about this in
England that there is a strain of
opinion which as well if Scotland leaves
they don't really care actually Peter
we're all passionately Pro unionists but
that's not necessarily the case in the
rest of the in the rest of England and
that's why there hasn't been a great
deal of coverage in the london-based
press of this debate because read is art
that says what mellifluous argues The
Times this morning that the the
Britishness
as a currency has collapsed in this
country over 15 20 years and the reason
James the people aren't making the M
emotional appeals that you've just done
is because relief they don't feel it
people think we are well reaping the
whirlwind of the failure to properly
teach narrative history in schools this
is what is coming home to roost which is
people don't understand enough about
what this country is and we've lost some
our sense of justified national pride um
has gone imma gonna have what if the
Scots do you vote no which I sincerely
hope they do we're gonna have to set
about rebuilding our sense of national
identity that it's going to have to be
one of the main priorities after this
vote